can you show the clip of the kiss that
Jill Biden and Kamala Harris if you can
find that while you're doing that go
ahead do you know who so did you see it
Roger when uh Joe Biden came down and I
didn't realize this her husband and his
name is Doug emoff he's the first second
gentleman of our entire political he's
kamala's husband and Jill Biden came
there and it wasn't just like listen
we're Middle Eastern yeah so Roger when
we when we see other family members you
know maybe a kiss some some people do
three they literally locked eyes and it
wasn't just okay accidental here it was
a it was a moment where even the people
around them were like are we are we on
camera right now and it's like if coma
like if that was somebody like my mom if
that was her over there then that
happened my mom would have jumped over I
don't give a damn jumped over these
aisles and beat the hell out of jail
like that's that's just it's just it's
ridiculous like look he knows he's about
to get he knows what's coming he's about
to give it to us he's the one that
initiated he starts okay can we see
who's the old lady in the middle little
that just stuck right there do you guys
know who that is don't recognize that's
probably that's probably like his mom or
something yeah can we play that Rob I
want to see that
oh no sound oh
that was a good one
look at that I love him more than three
that's on the lips right I mean that's
straight up on the list of course look
so so here's my first one here's my
question here's my question I think you
were born you can run for office right
you're essentially born in America so
everybody here is a natural citizen I'm
not so to me is this an American thing
like is it normal for one who to kiss
another
man's wife let alone is that an American
is that a normal thing to do no uh it's
this and this is just a distraction I
mean this is like a UK Daily Mail moment
you know uh but no I don't think it I
don't think it's a cultural thing by the
way you can run for anything but
president United States Pat could who
yes you yeah I'm not interested I
understand but just the fact that you're
uh not not Natural Born whatever that
means doesn't mean you couldn't run for
it yeah so I mean to me when I see
something like this I'm a little bit
weirded out by it you know to to say hey
it's okay to do something like this do
you find that weird as well is it just
me I found it very weird I was listening
to this in the car this morning and I
didn't even notice it until we we played
it back and I was like what that is very
weird and the internet has definitely
been been sharing this more than enough
and you guys know you guys know who that
is that's Paul Pelosi with the hat right
there and that's Bono on the left thank
God he didn't sing
yeah it was that's hilarious that would
have been hilarious yeah what would he
well it's just it's just an awkward
thing to do especially when you know all
the cameras are on you they're so
they're applauding you you just walked
into the room and then that's the first
like that's she didn't do this with
anybody else it was just it was just to
the second Jumpman so so does anybody
care is this like even anything so
meaning let's just say uh uh let's just
say Trump's wife kisses uh Mike Pence
Mike Pence it's kind of like doing that
right or is that like who would that be
no it would be Mike Pence's well that
doesn't work because it would be
opposite it's just still somebody's I
don't know man somebody's wife or
husband like locking lips or that I I
that was that right off the rip because
that was the first thing I saw I was
like oh my God that really just happen
and then he opened with calling uh Chuck
Schumer the uh minority what do you call
them right when he went on the stage he
had a gaff right off the right off the
rim so if you like this clip and you
want to watch another one click right
here and if you want to watch the entire
podcast click right here
[Music]